spawn Armageddon starring will not Keith
David hey whoa hi I'm back I guess after
like three months of only doing the
occasional live stream and posting a
[ __ ] zillion cosplay pics on Instagram
that's like six years in youtuber time
how is the platform evolved since I left
oh it's only gotten way worse okay well
even though YouTube is having a sad
Armageddon we won't let it deter us from
having a fun pocalypse of our own this
review was requested by New York
firefighter in Gotham cast member Diego
Rivera for the $100 tier on patreon he's
done some reviews of games over on his
channel too and they're really great go
check him out he was gonna do like a
spawn game's retrospective thing but I
guess he just decided to hand this one
off to me for some reason
maybe because he was going to be forced
to review it under duress and he'd
rather I suffer it instead well I sure
I'm spending a lot of time not talking
about this spawn game okay fine let's
get into it
I'm a little rusty with writing these
please bear with me it's not my first
time reviewing something with Todd's
greatest embarrassment even though I
think he's pretty cool still he can also
watch my video about that awesome
animated series spawn had that was great
is this great probably not let's find
out a gameplay I guess well this one's a
pretty typical third-person hacky sack
and slash in which he plays a Simmons a
ripoff of Ghost Rider that not enough
people call out for that you can swing
your axe
you can shoot projectile weapons and you
can very awkwardly platformer right off
the bat I loaded this game up and I
hated the controls because the melee is
circle in the projectiles square plus a
bunch of other dumb stuff this feels so
awkward to play that I never got used to
it and instead opted to rebind all the
buttons to something closer to like a
standard spectacle fighter like your god
wars or your Devil May Cry is or your
heavy rains although I very quickly
noticed an issue okay so check out my
basic combo with the axe alright here's
a heavy attack maybe I can mix those two
up a little kind of but not really well
then let's just yeah no that's that's
all there is you can't do a single other
thing with this axe just these same four
hits that kneecaps a huge amount of the
gameplay right there it gets so tedious
because you feel like you get no variety
in the combat
it also doesn't help that this enemy AI
is sort of weird and busted sometimes
you can just stand behind them and hit
them in the back of the head like an
urban inner-city youth Svein and they
have no defense for it
turn around spider-man over there
alternatively Al Bundy doesn't have a
block ability either so if they hit you
the long combo attack you got to just
stand there and take it like brackets
clever comic pun [ __ ] I forgot the right
one again
well the melee combat is a snoozefest
but you get a pretty decent amount of
different projectile weapons honestly it
feels like they all do the same amount
of damage and I can't tell a couple of
them apart in the heat of combat some of
these weapons are also so big that you
can hardly walk while carrying them and
it can really mess you up like alright
say you're fighting someone with pistols
but they run out of ammo it'll default
you to carrying this weapon that's so
huge you can't jump or run and it leaves
you open to a lot of cheap shots
it's just clunky and frustrating the
magic powers are pretty useless for
damage and it's easy to forget you have
them just use these chains they can be
used indefinitely they don't need to
recharge they do a decent amount of
damage and you can just casually
sidestep around your enemies while
poking them repeatedly god that just
looks more annoying than badass
[ __ ] stop just stop poking me with
the chain spawn stop why are you come on
man what's the stop walking out of the
[ __ ] spawns walk cycle was really
stilted and it looks like he has to take
a poo but he's not quite sure where the
bathroom is so he's just kind of
clenching it while going about his daily
activities look at him poor bastard is
pretending nothing's wrong is this a
metaphor for the comics industry in the
90s how the hell do you not have more
than one combo for a melee weapon
I mean clearly whoever made this is
taking some inspiration from like Devil
May Cry but that's one of the basics of
a game like this or think of like a game
like God of War from around that time
you have like 20 moves you could do and
mixing it up was fun this is such a
basic thing to screw up yeah this has
Cod McFarland written all over it
not being able to do basic things like
have spawns show up in your spawn movie
Sam and twitch are the real stars here I
ship those key boys what else is there
to talk about
well the platforming is awkward and
knowing sometimes offspring will grab
onto a Ledge and hop up sometimes he'll
just say you're my [ __ ] and
intentionally plummet to his death
particularly in this mission where you
go to Boulder Colorado and keep slipping
off the roofs of these numerous
marijuana dispensaries and internet
cafes well it's like my brand of humor
is just replacing nouns with the
incorrect thing and that's it watch this
show I'm obnoxious I reassigned the
controls so I could do this chained
gravel thing with the r2 button to
simulate the feeling of playing a normal
video game made for humans it's still
kind of awkward to control and sometimes
you can knock yourself out of it by
hitting the button more than once which
has led me to falling on my incredibly
toned spawn ass many a time because I'm
not playing with an a log controller
like the game said the environments feel
very appropriate for spawn there's a
huge amount of variation in the levels
that keep them looking fresh I
appreciate that part a lot and this game
just looks like 90's comics to me dirty
back alleys covered in trash grimy
rooftops overly shiny space stations and
hell I gotta admit this is a pretty
uncreated hell
why does hell always look the same
whenever you get there just floating
rocks and spikes and oceans of lava
why can't he'll be something more
creative and fun like an infinitely
expanding Nazi internment camp or school
or the clock oasis class ends in five
minutes but the bell never rings and the
teacher is making your realer and basic
morality while hitting you with a ruler
oh wait what about a youtube comment
section Rev Rowland just calls you a
virgin or says your voice is annoying
because you didn't like the same video
game as them is there a way to turn off
comment out of occations for one
specific video and still be able to see
all the other ones because my
self-esteem is in the dumpster right now
and that video just keeps getting more
views
sad guys I'm taking fluoxetine now
please the story of this game is about
as complex as you'd expect devils and
angels show up and start fighting on
earth spawn gets confused and just wants
them to stop and also a laser gets shot
at Central Park and creates a soul nado
he basically runs around meeting random
characters from his side cast and they
all tell him that princess is in another
castle until he eventually meets with
Satan himself well actually it's mal
bozo and technically he's not the same
entity as Satan but he's basically Satan
to get the answer that well heaven just
decided to build a space station and
blow up earth because Hell will no
longer be a problem
[Music]
[Music]
is todd mcfarlane a Scientologist what
does God mean with a spaceship we're
collaborating with angels now spawn
isn't voiced by Keith David so I have to
automatically doc points but on top of
that the voice I hear in this game is
just dark laser from Fairly OddParents
and that makes it way worse
[Music]
the boss fights are interesting in that
the character designs are rad and some
of the ideas are pretty cool but often
the execution makes them feel a little
flat wow this is really made by Todd
McFarlane both times you fight the
violation Klan Luigi guy you're just
walking around them on these raised
platforms and using projectiles there's
something about both of these fights
that makes them feel unfinished like
this is the first phase of a three phase
boss fight but now you just side strafe
and poke him with the chains and you
can't really do much to stop you you
also fight a spider tank a bulldozer
with a mouth on it an animatronic cyborg
gorilla and this cool guy named the
Redeemer who has a neat costume okay
he's voiced by John DiMaggio and it
makes it a little hard to take him
seriously unfortunately because he just
you know you just hear Jake the dog and
bender you will return to Angels Station
with me if you fight me
god I hope no one makes erotic fan art
of this thing it's a robot and an animal
it's too easy of a target all these
bosses are kind of lame except the first
one with Redeemer I think I enjoyed
having a one-on-one battle with like a
normal guy who had his own set of
heavenly powers to counter mine it felt
really cool and I liked the arena that
the fight took place in it wasn't super
complicated but it just felt more
interesting than the usual junk then for
the final boss he's just another spider
tank well okay now he's a scorpion tank
then he's a big guy who you can poke out
with the chains these chains don't even
look like they're coming out of spawns
belt a lot of the time I'm not gonna lie
okay most of this game is relatively
easy and linear but the last few areas
are a nightmare trainwreck of level
design because they stopped being linear
and it's so jarring now you're put into
these big areas where you need to run
around looking for stuff
hey ghostwriter how's it going buddy
be doing something different with your
hair the heav'n station mission is
probably one of the most irritating
levels in any game I've played the
layout of this place is so hard to keep
track of the enemies here are weird and
I never could figure out the rules of
how the shield on them works sometimes
there and sometimes it isn't whatever
phew these angel warrior ladies that are
no way legally affiliated with the
character of Angela created known by
Neil Gaiman and trademarked by Marvel
Comics
have this weird attack where they shoot
fireballs in the air and it just hits
you in the head over and over when they
do this your only strategy is to just
book it and take shelter until it's over
the only way to progress this level is
to find all of these canisters and smash
them real good but this place is a maze
eventually I got angry and started
trying to save myself time by bugging it
hitting these things through the walls
which worked pretty well also speaking a
bug is this level has a nasty habit of
freezing when you jump too much it
happened to me four times but I only
managed to record two of them
[Music]
well whoa I could definitely ah dude the
game crashed again this is a problemo
I remember xavier mention indeed this
problem - that the game kept crashing in
this mission this is not good
Jesus guys give me a break here my walk
cycle has a hard time getting up flights
of stairs I'm a handi-capable helpline
ok so like after you spent several hours
smashing these things and running around
these obnoxious mazes where everything
looks the same you wonder where you go
the original room has enemies that spawn
pet forever you think all this spinning
weird [ __ ] on the walls would be related
to getting up to that higher level but
nah you got to wait for this platform in
the middle to raise up and if you miss
it you're gonna be waiting for what
feels like several minutes for it to
come back then it gets to the ground and
then you wait for what feels like
several minutes for it to go up again
god damn I feel more depressed than Al
Simmons know the real al Simmons that
todd mcfarlane named the character after
and then sued for saying that he named
the character after him thanks Todd
alright so I'm finally up on the second
level of this place and it's filled with
so many enemies I can't fight them all
my health is already low from playing
fetch quest downstairs so I'm just
running past them this game rarely gives
you an objective so I'll just smash
anything that looks important like
whatever these things are now I'm stuck
in this room where the door won't open
because God hates spawn literally
alright time to do another one of my
last stand things I'll fight everything
in this room until eventually the door
opens and they leave me alone
thanks crotch chains I can poke any
enemy to death with you finally I can
get to the last boss yeah he's pretty
lame earlier spawn and male bulge made a
deal that gene Simmons can finally be
human again if he makes sure that the
laser doesn't fire a second time but it
fires off just as the station explodes
and spawn goes home so we get the best
ending ever no it's time for Mel
bozhe to fulfill his side of the bargain
I'm afraid that won't be happening my
friend what you were promised your
humanity if the weapon was never fired
again but indeed it was every penny but
no yeah I don't really recommend this
one like it's fine not terrible it's
fine but geez if they worked on it for
like another year it could have been
really great
all right Diego balls in your court I
reviewed your crappy spawn game now you
got to do me a solid and review the
Catwoman game because God knows I'm not
gonna touch that one
this game has taught me a valuable
lesson though even though the world
around us is going to hell and we all
can't do much to stop it we can still
put in some effort and then get no
reward at all for our hard work well
I'll see you next time
and what a dumb game
[Music]
[Music]